[Music]
[Applause]
uh are we uh G to dive into this
Michigan story here uh Austin Meek he is
a staff writer covering Michigan
football and basketball for the athletic
he's written a couple of columns here
did a deep dive on this Austin kind
enough to join us here all right help me
understand what did Mi what is Michigan
accused of doing uh illegally
so there's an NCAA rule that's been on
the book since 1994 it says that teams
can't Scout their opponents in person
during the same season and the
allegation is that the staffer at
Michigan Connor stallions who's been
suspended was basically coordinating
this off-campus scouting ring buying
tickets at other big 10 stadiums and
other stadiums around the country and
then coordinating people to go in and
watch the games and film the signals of
the other teams which at least according
to the spirit of the NCAA rule would be
a
violation what if you're not filming
what if you're just observing I mean it
like how deep does this go that makes it
illegal if I just go and I'm watching
watching your mannerisms your gestures
your signals is that illegal so there's
two actually two separate rules that
would be applicable one of them is about
technology and and filming and one of
them is just about scouting and the
definition of scouting is really vague
in the rule and I think that's part of
what this is going to hinge on is what
actually is scouting if you have
somebody who's just a fan in the stands
observing the game does that person
count as a scout of your school and I
don't honestly know the answer to that I
think there will be a lot of technical
arguments made about the definition of a
scout and that's why I go back to the
the spirit of the rule is that you can't
do this but in terms of how the letter
of the law is interpreted I really don't
know the answer to that it's like
deflate gate I think the rule is silly
but if you're going to lie to the nciaa
or you know Jim Harbaugh says they
didn't do anything wrong um they're
already under investigation I guess for
you know what happened during coid uh he
says he wants to be the I think gold
standard here with his program uh is did
they offer him a contract extension this
season and and is that on the back
burner now yeah so we've reported that
before any of this came out Michigan was
in the process of working on a a massive
contract extension for Jim Harbaugh in
fact there had been hopes that that
would get done in the next couple weeks
and and my understanding is yeah that's
on the back burner now I I don't think
Michigan can sign Jim Harbaugh to a huge
contract extension with all of this
going down and it just you know the
timing of it is is not good for Michigan
given the fact that Jim Harbaugh served
a three-game suspension to start this
season they already have had NCAA issues
Michigan stood by Jim Harbaugh in the
midst of that but I have to imagine for
a similar thing to come up now in the
middle of this season as as Michigan is
undefeated and right now the favorite to
win the national championship it has to
be uh really disappointing for a lot of
people around Michigan doesn't this come
down to the commissioner of the Big 10
not the nciaa because the commissioner
of the Big 10 is going to determine they
have the authority they have the
exclusive authority to determine
sportsmanship violations if they've
occurred what the penalty should be so
this really isn't the NCAA this is the
new commissioner of the big I
believe I think Tony petiti is in a
really interesting position here the Big
10 was notified by the NCAA that the
NCAA was investigating this as a
potential infractions case and that put
the Big 10 I think in kind of a bind
because you're absolutely right the Big
10 has a responsibility to ensure Fair
competition in its games Tony petiti has
the authority to punish Michigan or Jim
Harbaugh if if they deem that to be
justified at the same time I think that
the the Big 10 is trying to keep a
little bit of distance and not get in
the way of the NCAA investigation defer
to the NCAA since they have been
informed that the NCAA is investigating
but I I would think knowing what we know
about the NCAA process and how long it
takes I think there will be some
pressure on the Big 10 uh in the
meantime to step in and do something if
it seems like the Integrity of big 10
football games has been compromised and
I wonder because if the NCAA is left to
rule on this this could take years um
but the Big 10 like that could be
something that they could rule on I'm
going to guess pretty soon if they found
enough or imagine Michigan winning a
national title uh you know that's going
to stoke this up as you know the further
they go along this season the more
successful it's like the Astros where
you go well they're cheating well you
know they're somehow cheating and then I
know that there's some internet sleuths
who are posting photos here of the
signals of videos of you know people who
are you know T trying to steal is that
the proof here that hey they have a card
a placard that has signs on it that
shows you know what teams are calling or
maybe they're uh their audibles there
well no so a lot of the videos that have
surfaced on social media the ones of
Connor stallions on the sideline
standing next to Michigan's coordinators
that's actually all perfectly legal sign
stealing isn't illegal in college
football every program does it every
program probably has a card with other
team signals on it so the real question
is how was Connor stallion Gathering the
information that he used to try to
decode the other team's signals he had a
reputation in Michigan's program as a
guy who was really good at decoding
signals but was he doing it in a way
that broke NCAA rules and so really I
think the incriminating evidence is
going to be if there's somehow video
evidence of people that can be tied back
to Michigan in other stadiums taking
video if if the NCAA is able to get
Connor stallion's computer and can see
that people were sending him videos of
signals I think that would be much more
incriminating than anything that would
surface of him on the Michigan sideline
but Austin why don't they get up get you
know up to speed with modern technology
and have the communication in the helmet
just like you know there are high school
teams that have this why why doesn't the
NCAA or at least you know certain
conferences have this yeah been a big
push I think if anything comes of this I
won't be surprised if if this situation
is the Catalyst for inh helmet
communication to happen in college
football the way it happens in the NFL I
think there are lots of reasons why it
it hasn't happened and one of the
reasons may be that teams still feel
like they can get a competitive
Advantage by operating in these gray
areas and teams don't like to give that
up uh but I think certainly from the Big
10 perspective and I think a lot of
people around college football are going
to look at this situation and say this
is this is just a a scandal waiting to
happen to continue to not have the inh
helmet communication and create this
gray area that it appears that Michigan
and probably some other programs have
been trying to exploit well you had Dion
saying it's not a big deal Matt rule
said it's not a big deal it's almost
like hey I know my pitcher is scuffing
up the ball and your pitcher is probably
scuffing up the ball let's just call the
whole thing off we're not going to you
know tattle on each other but the
importance of this with Ohio State and
their media this isn't go away anytime
soon but I'm just curious what happens
next well Dan I think you're right that
that the Big 10 will have some decisions
to make and if we're looking for some
sort of punishment to happen soon I
think it would either have to be
something from Michigan or or something
from the Big 10 because we know how the
NCAA works but it's it's hard for me to
to see that happening unless there's
something really really conclusive I I
don't think the Big 10 wants to step in
and suspend Jim Harbaugh or declare
Michigan ineligible for the Big 10
championship game when this team is
ranked number two and and undefeated
that certainly wouldn't be good for the
league if Michigan is not eligible so I
think there are going to be some hard
decisions to make as as more comes out
there may be increasing pressure for
something to happen uh but I it's just
hard for me to see anybody really
stepping in and and derailing this
Michigan team that could very well play
for a national championship you've done
a great job on this the last two columns
I've read a lot of information in there
uh Austin thanks for joining us all
right thanks Dan Austin Meek staff
writer covering Michigan football and
basketball for the athletic